his first Royal Engagement put Prince
Louis in the driving seat
learning the ropes and stealing the show
The Prince and Princess of Wales brought
the whole family to the big help out
with the scouts here in Slough
Prince George Keen to lend a hand and
Charlotte's on target with the
volunteering message the defining theme
of the weekend has been service hasn't
it and we've seen that writ large today
with the big help out and to have had
the
support of The Prince and Princess of
Wales and the rest of the family as well
just goes to show that as a family you
can get involved in volunteering
coronation aside we've never seen them
together at an engagement
sign of Grandpa but the Firepower of his
wider family out in force the Duke and
Duchess of Edinburgh meeting guide dogs
in training and a Gloucester Cathedral
service for the Princess Royal to thank
volunteers
the coronation placed the royal family
in the spotlight for three days but
already questions on what next it's
generated a range of views and
interpretations and also there is
definitely now more a questioning about
the monarchy perhaps than there has been
for decades a desire for more
information about the accountability or
not and the transparency or not of the
monarchy
the fences are gone and soon Flags will
be down as the coronation comes to a
close everyone will come away with a
different memory from this weekend we've
seen spectacle on a huge scale the king
commanding the military convening world
leaders and celebrities but is it enough
to convince people the monarchy still
matters
and to that the celebrations short-lived
from official photos we have a portrait
of the working Royals the king says it
was a special occasion newly crowned but
this week straight back to work Laura
bundock Sky News